You said this place was steps from the water. We just haven't found the steps yet. How much did we save? Enough. Enough to get lost! Or you could book a stay with Hilton. Welcome to your oceanfront room. Just steps from the water.
你曾说过这个地方离水边只有几步之遥。我们只是还没找到那些台阶。我们省了多少钱？够了。够去迷失自我了！或者你也可以在希尔顿预订房间。欢迎来到你的海滨客房。距离水边仅几步之遥。
The Hilton sale is on now. Book on Hilton.com or the Hilton app and save up to 20% to get the stay you expected. When you want savings, not surprises. It matters where you stay. Hilton, for the stay. From roaring leaf blowers to screeching trains to your neighbor's loud music, the world is full of unwelcome noise.
希尔顿促销活动正在进行中。在Hilton.com或希尔顿应用程序上预订，即可享受高达20%的折扣，获得您期望的住宿体验。当您想要的是省钱，而不是惊吓。您住在哪里很重要。希尔顿，伴您好梦。从轰鸣的吹叶机到刺耳的火车，再到邻居的嘈杂音乐，世界充满了不受欢迎的噪音。
Noise pollution is more than just a nuisance. Researchers have found that noisy environments can take a real toll on people's mental and physical health. So what makes something noise as opposed to sound and what kinds of noises can be harmful? How does noise affect people's health and well-being? How to noisy and noise? environments affect kids learning? Is noise mostly a problem in cities or is noise pollution more widespread? And what can be done to mitigate noises effects and give us all a little more peace and quiet? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological
噪声污染不仅仅是一种烦恼。研究人员发现，嘈杂的环境会严重损害人们的身心健康。那么，究竟是什么让某种声音区别于噪音？什么样的噪音会具有危害性？噪音如何影响人们的健康和福祉？嘈杂的环境如何影响儿童的学习？噪音主要是一个城市问题吗？还是噪声污染更加普遍？可以采取什么措施来减轻噪音的影响，给我们所有人带来更多的宁静？欢迎收听《心理学之声》，这是美国心理学会的旗舰播客
Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. My guest today is Dr. Arlene Braunzaft, a professor emerita of psychology at the city University of New York. She's an environmental psychologist who's been studying noise for more than five decades, beginning with landmark research in the 1970s that looked at the effects of noise from an elevated subway line in Manhattan on children's learning in a school next to the trains. She's also an advocate. She's been appointed by five New York mayors to the board of the environmental nonprofit, Roe, NYC, where she oversees its noise activities, and she assisted in the 2007 revision of New York City's Noise Code. She's co-author of the 2011 book Why Noise Matters
该播客探讨心理学科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯。我今天的嘉宾是纽约市立大学心理学荣休教授阿琳·布朗扎夫特博士。她是一位环境心理学家，研究噪音已有五十多年，始于20世纪70年代的标志性研究，该研究调查了曼哈顿高架铁路线的噪音对火车旁一所学校里儿童学习的影响。她也是一位倡导者。她被五位纽约市长任命为环保非营利组织“纽约成长”（Grow NYC）的董事会成员，她在那里监督其噪音活动，并协助修订了2007年纽约市的噪音法规。她是2011年出版的书籍《为什么噪音很重要》的合著者
and the children's book, Listen to the Rain Drops. And she's been interviewed by many media outlets, including the New York Times and New York Magazine, which recently called her the noise queen of New York City. Dr. Bruncef, thank you for joining me today. Thank you for invited me. Let's start with the most basic question. When does a sound become noise? And can the same sound be just sound to somebody and noise to another person? We know sound is a physical phenomenon. And it goes through our ears and it gets to our brain and we identify the sound. That's sound.
以及儿童读物《听雨滴》。她接受了许多媒体的采访，包括《纽约时报》和《纽约杂志》，该杂志最近称她为“纽约市的噪音女王”。布朗扎夫特博士，感谢您今天加入我的节目。谢谢邀请我。让我们从最基本的问题开始。声音在什么时候会变成噪音？同一个声音对某个人来说可能只是声音，而对另一个人来说却是噪音吗？我们知道声音是一种物理现象。它穿过我们的耳朵，到达我们的大脑，我们识别出这个声音。那是声音。
But when you talk about noise, you're talking about sounds that are unwanted, intrusive, bothersome, disturbing. And now because of literature, as you cited, linking noise. to adverse mental and health effects, we now say that noise is an environmental pollutant. And let me add that noise doesn't have to be loud to be that disturbing. Picture yourself trying to fall asleep next to a bathroom with a dripping faucet. That's not loud. Or my daughter trying to study in her bedroom and the person above playing music,
但是当你谈论噪音时，你谈论的是那些不想要的、侵入性的、烦人的、令人不安的声音。现在，由于正如你所引用的文献将噪音与不利的精神和健康影响联系起来，我们现在说噪音是一种环境污染物。让我补充一点，噪音不一定很大才会让人感到不安。想象一下，你试图在一间水龙头漏水的浴室旁边入睡。那声音不大。或者我女儿试图在她的卧室里学习，而楼上的人在放音乐，
which he didn't like, by the way. But the point was the music wasn't that loud, but it disturbed her. And that's the difference between sound and noise. Now, I mentioned in my intro that you've been studying noise since the 1970s when you did that landmark research on how noise affected learning in classrooms. Can you tell us a little bit about that and how you first got involved in noise research? Well, I am an environmental psychologist, so we look at the environment and the impacts of elements in the environment. We would look at noise, right? We would look at crowds. And so I was giving a lecture at Lehman College, part of the City University of New York, on noise. A student came up to me at the end of the class and said, my child goes to a school next to elevated trainer. noise and the passing trains disturbed the children every four minutes. They're not able to learn. And the teacher's probably going to have a difficult time teaching. And she said, we're going to sue the city of New York because the noise we believe is intruding on their learning. And as the wife of an
顺便说一句，她不喜欢那个音乐。但重点是音乐并没有那么大声，但它打扰了她。这就是声音和噪音的区别。现在，我在开场白中提到，你自20世纪70年代以来一直在研究噪音，当时你对噪音如何影响课堂学习进行了那项标志性的研究。你能给我们讲讲那件事以及你最初是如何参与噪音研究的吗？嗯，我是一名环境心理学家，所以我们研究环境以及环境中各种元素的影响。我们会研究噪音，对吧？我们会研究人群。因此，当时我在纽约市立大学旗下的雷曼学院就讲授关于噪音的课程。下课时，一个学生走到我面前说，我的孩子去了一所紧邻高架铁路线的学校。噪音和经过的火车每四分钟就会打扰孩子们一次。他们无法学习。老师教课可能也会很困难。她说，我们要起诉纽约市，因为我们认为噪音正在侵扰他们的学习。作为一个律师的妻子，
attorney, I said, you need data to prove that the sounds from the trains, are disrupting the learning in the classroom. And she turned to me and she said, can you help us? And that was it. I went to the principal of the school. The school was a perfect setting in a natural setting. Half the school, the classrooms were exposed to the trains. On the quiet side of the building, no sounds of that nature.
我说，你需要数据来证明来自火车的音响正在扰乱课堂学习。她转过身对我说，你能帮我们吗？就是这样。我去找了学校的校长。这所学校是一个完美的自然环境。学校的一半教室暴露在火车旁。在建筑安静的一侧，没有那种性质的声音。
I compared the reading scores that were provided to me by the principal of the children next to the trains and the reading scores of the children on the quiet side. And by the sixth grade, the children were nearly a year behind in reading when exposed to the noise. That's considerable. And let me tell you, that study got lots of attention. The press was there, the media, the public officials, the parents. Everyone was so disturbed by what they learned from that study.
我比较了校长提供的坐在火车旁的孩子的阅读分数和安静一侧孩子的阅读分数。到了六年级，接触噪音的孩子的阅读能力落后了将近一年。这相当惊人。而且我告诉你，那项研究引起了极大的关注。媒体、公众官员、家长都在场。每个人都对从那项研究中了解到的情况感到非常不安。
But then I realized the mother had asked me to help her child. Publishing a paper did not do that. I had to advocate to lessen the noise next to those classrooms. having contacts with some people at the Transit Authority. I met with them. They told me they were testing out a program to lessen noise on the tracks. They were going to be installing rubber resilient pads. I said, okay, choose the school in Inwood.
但后来我意识到，母亲是请我帮她的孩子。发表一篇论文并不能做到这一点。我必须倡导减少这些教室旁边的噪音。由于与交通局的一些人有联系，我与他们进行了会面。他们告诉我，他们正在测试一个旨在减少轨道噪音的项目。他们将安装橡胶弹性垫。我说，好吧，选择因伍德的那所学校。
Choose the school I did my study. Test out the rubber resilient pads. And I went to the Board of Ed and said, how can we get acoustical tiles in the ceilings of those classrooms? Now, people say to me, both agencies in New York City listened to you is a little unusual. But I did have all the support. And the New York Times was also supportive. That helps.
选择我做研究的那所学校。测试橡胶弹性垫。然后我去了教育局，问我们如何在那些教室的天花板上安装吸音砖。现在，人们对我说，纽约市的两个机构都听取了你的意见，这很不寻常。但我确实得到了所有的支持。《纽约时报》也给予了支持。这很有帮助。
And then they did test out the rubber resilient pads by placing it there. and they then asked me, actually a public official, say, go back, Dr. Brodzaf, see if it helped. Well, I went back. And I was so pleased to be able to say that now with the pads installed, the noise lesson, the teachers were happier in the classroom, the children were, and guess what, children on both sides of the building were really, at the same level. And those two studies, which were then reinforced by further studies that found that noise impacted on children's learning, changed my life.
然后他们确实通过在那里放置橡胶弹性垫进行了测试。他们随后要求我，实际上是一位官员说，回去吧，布朗扎夫特博士，看看它是否有帮助。好吧，我回去了。我非常高兴地宣布，现在随着垫子的安装，噪音减弱了，教室里的老师更高兴了，孩子们也是，你猜怎么着，建筑物两侧的孩子实际上处于同一水平。这两项研究随后得到了进一步研究的加强，这些研究发现噪音影响了儿童的学习，改变了我的生活。
Because I didn't just publish two papers that are now considered landmark research, I got involved in noise. And I found people coming to me with all sorts of noise. and saying, help me. Now, you were able to get those changes. That was back in the 70s. What has happened subsequently? Does the Transit Authority, are they still making changes to abate noise?
因为我不仅发表了两篇现在被认为是标志性研究的论文，我还参与了噪音研究。我发现人们带着各种各样的噪音来找我，并说，帮帮我。现在，你当时能够实现这些改变。那是70年代的事了。后来发生了什么？交通局还在做出改变以消除噪音吗？
Transit Authority actually asked me to come in and help them with respect to noise abatement. And I worked with their engineers. And I, a psychologist, no engineering background, was able to provide information on how to design acquired a traction motor, I worked with them. And while I was there, noise was elevated. It's not a top priority at the transit authority. So when I was involved, yes, they were doing things along the system. They then said they were to put in this resilient pads near all the schools.
交通局实际上邀请我进去帮助他们解决噪音减弱问题。我与他们的工程师合作。而我，一个没有工程背景的心理学家，能够提供关于如何设计更安静的牵引电动机的信息，我与他们合作。当我在那里时，噪音得到了重视。它不是交通局的最高优先事项。所以当我参与时，是的，他们正在整个系统沿线做一些事情。他们随后表示他们将在所有学校附近安装这些弹性垫。
I think there were 54 of them. I said, uh-uh. People live near the tracks. That should be a program. for the entire system. They agreed. And today, you're calling me, doing this interview rather,
我想有54个。我说，呃-Uh。人们住在轨道附近。那应该是一个针对整个系统的项目。他们同意了。今天，你打电话给我，或者说进行这次采访，
a very appropriate time, there's been increased noises in the transit system, which they're studying, and I was so pleased I was able to call someone who's been there for 35 years, so I knew this person, and I'm now going to be working
在一个非常合适的时间，交通系统中的噪音有所增加，他们正在对此进行研究。我非常高兴能够联系到一个在那里工作了35年的人，所以我认识这个人，我现在将与纽约大学的研究人员和交通局合作，重新审视那些变得更加吵闹的火车。但我认为采取了行动。你必须给教育局和交通局打高分，并考虑到他们接纳了一个让他们难堪的人。还记得第一次研究结果出来的时候吗？我在交通局并不受欢迎。但他们说，你知道吗？让我们一起努力，试着让系统安静下来。所以我认为这里有教训可以吸取，关于人们如何合作并解决问题。所以我给他们打高分。
with researchers in NYU and the Transit Authority to revisit the trains that have gotten noisier. But I think that action was taken. You've got to give high grades to the Board of Education and the Transit Authority and to think that they took a person that embarrassed them. Remember when those first study results came in, I wasn't popular. at the Transit Authority. But they said, you know what? Let's work together and let's try to quiet the system. So I think there are lessons to be learned here of how people can cooperate and get a problem solved. So I give them high grades. What else do we know about the effects of noise on the physical and mental health of people? How has the research advanced since you first did
关于噪音对人们身心健康的影响，我们还知道什么？自从你最初做那些研究以来，研究是如何进展的？
those studies? The research has indeed advanced. I've done two other studies on the effects of aircraft noise on health, but didn't have large samples. So I basically found that the people were being disturbed and their quality of life has been diminished. Studies have now linked noise to cardiovascular disorders so that if people are living with aircraft noise and you can't imagine unless you're exposed, to it, how awful that is. They are at an increased risk to be entering hospitals with cardiovascular disturbances. Sleep loss has been linked in studies to noise. Sleep is essential for good health. So the literature is confirming this. I'm actually working with a professor at Columbia, who will be shortly doing a study on the effects of community noise, on sleep of people living in that community.
研究确实取得了进展。我做过另外两项关于飞机噪音对健康影响的研究，但样本量不大。所以我基本上发现人们受到了干扰，他们的生活质量下降了。研究现在已将噪音与心血管疾病联系起来，如果人们生活在飞机噪音中，除非你亲身体验，否则你无法想象那是多么糟糕。他们进入医院患心血管疾病的风险有所增加。研究已将睡眠丧失与噪音联系起来。睡眠对健康至关重要。因此文献证实了这一点。我实际上正在与哥伦比亚大学的一位教授合作，他不久将进行一项关于社区噪音对生活在该社区的人们睡眠影响的研究。
So the studies are there. They've been replicated. They have found that noise is harmful to health. But now let's take mental health. I wish you would be in my home when I get a call from someone has a noise problem. the anguish, the distress, the unhappiness, the frustration of not having this be resolved, having been exposed to neighbor noise maybe five, six years, haven't been exposed to noise coming from a venue in the neighborhood. Those are psychological effects. Distress, disturbance. Now, while the stress, which comes with stress, which comes with stress, stress and disturbance can lead to physiological disorders, the mental discomfort and anguish and unhappiness has been identified throughout the world. And let me add this. You may not yet
所以研究就在那里。它们已被复制。它们发现噪音对健康有害。但现在让我们来看看心理健康。我希望你能在我接到有噪音问题的电话时在我的家里。那种痛苦、苦恼、不快乐、问题无法解决的frustration，可能已经接触邻居噪音五年、六年了，接触到社区某个场馆传来的噪音。这些都是心理影响。痛苦、干扰。现在，虽然伴随着压力的苦恼，压力和干扰可以导致生理失调，但心理上的不适、痛苦和不快乐已经在世界各地得到了确认。让我补充一点。你可能还没有
have become ill. Your blood pressure may not have yet risen to a point where you need medication. But you know what? You're not living a decent quality of life. Quality of life is important. It's not just enough to be alive. My daughter, who lives in Queens with aircraft noise, cannot enjoy her backyard. Wow, COVID came, and what a comfort that was. No planes, birds singing, and being viewed as she sat and enjoyed her backyard. I can, think people are entitled to quiet in their homes and hopefully they will not develop more serious symptoms. But when they're being imposed by hazardous noise pollutants, they are missing out on living a decent quality of life. Your summer starts now with Memorial Day deals at the
生病。你的血压可能还没有上升到需要服药的地步。但你知道吗？你没有过上体面的生活质量。生活质量很重要。仅仅活着是不够的。我住在皇后区、饱受飞机噪音折磨的女儿，无法享受她的后院。哇，新冠疫情来了，那是多么大的安慰啊！没有飞机，鸟儿在歌唱，当她坐着享受后院时，被视为……我认为人们有权在自己的家中享受安静，希望他们不会发展出更严重的症状。但当他们受到危险的噪音污染物的强加时，他们就错过了过上体面的生活质量的机会。你的夏天从家得宝（The Home Depot）的阵亡将士纪念日优惠开始。
Home Depot. It's time to fire up summer cookouts with the Next Grill, Four-Burner Gas Grill on special buy for only $199. And entertain all season with the Hampton Bay West Grove seven-piece outdoor dining set for only $499. This Memorial Day get low prices guaranteed at the Home Depot. While supplies, price invalid May 14th or May 27, U.S. only exclusions apply. See Home Depot.com slash price match for details. Can you become inured to noise like that? I mean, you live in Manhattan.
是时候用NexGrill四炉头燃气烤架开启夏日烧烤了，特价仅需199美元。整个季节尽情娱乐，购买汉普顿湾（Hampton Bay）韦斯特格罗夫七件套户外餐饮套装，仅需499美元。这个阵亡将士纪念日，在家得宝享受保证低价。售完即止，价格有效期截至5月14日或5月27日，仅限美国，适用除外条款。详情请参见Home Depot.com斜杠价格匹配。
I used to live in Manhattan. I know that it's very noisy eventually. You almost don't hear it anymore, but are you still experiencing the psychological and physiological effects? You notice that Manhattanites in certain areas walk very fast. Do you ever figure out why do they walk so fast? They're trying to get away from the noise. Sometimes a person you stop to ask for directions may not stop and talk to you. give that person a break.
你能习惯那样的噪音吗？我的意思是，你住在曼哈顿。我以前住在曼哈顿。我知道那里最终会非常吵闹。你几乎再也听不到它了，但你还在经历心理和生理影响吗？你注意到曼哈顿人在某些地区走得很快吗？你有没有想过为什么他们走得那么快？他们试图远离噪音。有时候你停下来问路的人可能不会停下来跟你聊。放过那个人吧。
That person's trying to get away for that noisy environment. But in my experience, I think most New Yorkers will stop and talk to you. Now, let's talk about getting accustomed to a sound. That requires work. That requires stress on your system. And that will cause an adverse effect. And I'm going to give you another term that comes up. learned helplessness, a psychological term, where a person feels no matter what I do, nothing is going to change.
那个人正试图逃离那个嘈杂的环境。但在我的经验中，我认为大多数纽约人都会停下来跟你聊天。现在，让我们来谈谈习惯某种声音。这需要付出努力。这会对你的系统造成压力。这会产生不利影响。我要给你另一个出现的术语。习得性无助，一个心理学术语，指一个人觉得无论我做什么，都不会改变什么。
I cannot make another phone call to my legislative assistant. I can't talk to my neighbor again. I have to learn to live with it. Living with noise is stress. It takes work to try. to cancel out the sounds and go on with your life. And that is costly to your health. Now, I mentioned that you're on the board of Grow NYC, a nonprofit,
我不能再给我的立法助理打电话了。我不能再跟我的邻居谈了。我必须学会忍受它。与噪音共存就是压力。试图屏蔽声音并继续你的生活需要付出努力。这对你的健康代价高昂。现在，我提到你是“纽约成长”（Grow NYC）这个非营利组织的董事会成员，
that people can contact when they have a concern or a dispute about noise, and your name and number are right there. Can you tell me about that work and the kinds of issues that you've dealt with over the years in that role? That's it. My name and the phone number is of the office. You get to grow on my scene, and Priscilla will contact me immediately and say, hey, we've gotten this call. So I have neighbor noise is very high on the list.
人们在对噪音有顾虑或争议时可以联系该组织，你的名字和电话号码就在那里。你能跟我谈谈那项工作以及你多年来在该角色中处理过的问题类型吗？就是这样。我的名字和办公室的电话号码。你联系“纽约成长”，普莉希拉会立即联系我，说，嘿，我们接到了这个电话。所以邻居噪音在名单上名列前茅。
I guess we live in a society where people lack respect, where people are not acting decently. Would a neighbor turn on her TV at 6 a.m. and blast music to the neighbor. next door or downstairs, if she were respectful, if she really cared about other people, so many of those problems are really rooted and people not caring about others. And we're living in a society where this is applicable to other issues as well. So when someone calls me, I listen to that person and their voice calms down and they get to feel better. I'm not a clinician. I haven't given them therapy. I've listened. And I've been the first person who has listened. And even though I haven't done anything to remedy the problem, the person is so
我想我们生活在一个缺乏尊重、人们行为不体面的社会里。如果一个邻居表现出尊重，如果她真的关心其他人，她会在早上6点打开电视，把音乐开到最大声放给隔壁或楼下的邻居听吗？许多这类问题实际上都根源于人们不关心他人。我们生活在一个这也适用于其他问题的社会中。所以当有人打电话给我时，我倾听那个人的声音，他们的声音平静下来，他们感觉好多了。我不是临床医生。我没有给他们做治疗。我倾听了。我是第一个倾听的人。即使我没有做任何事情来纠正这个问题，这个人也是如此
relieved. You listen to me. You understand. You will help me. Now, have I been able to help people? Have I gone to managing agents? Have I gone to board chairs? Have I gone to landlords? Yes. And I have to say that in many cases, I've been able to help people. I'm going to give you another example that I think people may be surprised at. One of the complaints people have is the music venues and their area are loud, or the doors are kept open, or the person lives downstairs. And I found that when the mayor of New York, de Blasio, the last mayor, appointed a nightlife mayor, I found that I could reach out to her, call the person who she reported to, and met with her. And she said she cared about noise. And I said, good, we'll work together. And I did have a few complaints that dealt with music venues.
如释重负。你听我说。你明白了。你会帮我的。那么，我是否能够帮助过别人呢？我是否找过管理代理人？我是否找过董事会主席？我是否找过房东？是的。而且我必须说，在许多情况下，我都能够帮助别人。我要给你举另一个例子，我想大家可能会感到意外。人们抱怨的问题之一是他们地区的音乐场所声音太大，或者门一直开着，或者有人住在楼下。我发现，当纽约市长德布拉西奥（上任市长）任命了一位夜生活市长时，我发现我可以联系她，给她汇报工作的人打电话，并与她会面。她说她很关心噪音问题。我说，好，我们会一起合作。我确实处理了一些涉及音乐场所的投诉。
but I had someone to call and someone who would work with me. It turned out she retired from the position, but she contacted the person who replaced her. He and I have already talked and will work together. The other thing is these music venues belong to a national group, and they were meeting in New York City, and I was invited to speak to these venues from all over the country and how important it was to lessen the sound level of their music.
但我有电话可打，也有人会和我合作。后来她从这个职位上退休了，但她联系了接替她的人。我和他已经交谈过，并且会合作。另一件事是，这些音乐场所属于一个全国性组织，他们当时在纽约市开会，我应邀向来自全国各地的这些场所发表讲话，谈谈降低音乐音量是多么重要。
Be aware that you can be intrusive. Keep the doors closed. And I did a podcast with one of the people from the organization, which has been circulated throughout to all the groups. So I guess I do things in a reasonable fashion. I listen. And by the way, when a person contacts me with a noise problem, when I write to the landlord or to the managing agent, I always say, let's talk and let's see how I can work with you to resolve the problem. And I find that if we just respected each other a bit, we know that we shouldn't have stomping on a wooden floor at five in the morning.
要注意，你可能会打扰到别人。保持门关着。我和该组织的一位成员做了一个播客，该播客已在所有组织中广为流传。所以我想我做事还是比较理性的。我倾听。顺便说一句，当有人因为噪音问题联系我时，当我写信给房东或管理代理人时，我总是说，我们谈谈吧，看看我如何能与你合作解决这个问题。我发现，如果我们稍微尊重彼此一点，我们就会知道，我们不应该在早上五点钟在地板上跺脚。
And if you go to our site, we have a brochure that could be downloaded. And this brochure was written years ago. And all I say is be respectful. Be aware that your sounds may not be wanted by others. Now, you're unusual in that you have this position in the city of New York. Are there comparable people in other cities? Is there a network of people who do what you do? I belong to organizations across the country.
如果你访问我们的网站，我们有一份可以下载的小册子。这本小册子是多年前写的。我只想说，要懂得尊重。要意识到别人可能并不希望听到你的声音。现在，你在纽约市拥有这个职位很不寻常。其他城市有类似的人吗？有一个和你做同样事情的人的网络吗？我属于全国各地的组织。
I am the honorary chair, one organization called Quiet Communities, in which I work with groups on aircraft noise. And what's happened lately is across the country, groups on aircraft noise are growing readily and very knowledgeable, very involved. No, I don't think there's a comparable person as I've been, you know, appointed to grow NYC where I have other obligations as well. But I want people to also know that it's not just an urban problem. You raise that. So I'm going to say to you, know where my expert witness cases are for which I get paid?
我是“安静社区”这一组织的荣誉主席，在该组织中，我与各团体合作解决飞机噪音问题。最近发生的情况是，在全国范围内，致力于飞机噪音的团体正在迅速壮大，他们知识渊博，参与度极高。不，我认为没有一个可以与我相提并论的人，你知道，我被任命来发展纽约市，我也有其他的职责。但我还想让人们知道，这不仅仅是一个城市问题。你提出了这一点。所以我要对你说，你知道我的专家证人案都是在哪里进行的，而且我还能得到报酬吗？
How would you like Montana? How would you like Wyoming? And I know you smiled. What? Montana, Wyoming? All right, picture this. You're 62 years old, your husband's 65. You've both retired and you purchased a home in a senior citizen community. And it's so beautiful. And you have a backyard. And you're living there a short time when you hear a motorcross raceway will be built next to your home. How do you think you're going to feel? feel about that. And so I was called in as an expert witness by the attorneys. And you can ask, was the motorcross raceway built? The answer is no. And although I could say my testimony helped, what impressed me was the decision by the judge who stated that noise intrudes on the well-being of people. And that impressed me. And I had a similar case in Wyoming. I've also
蒙大拿州怎么样？怀俄明州怎么样？我知道你笑了。什么？蒙大拿州、怀俄明州？好吧，想象一下这个场景。你62岁，你丈夫65岁。你们都退休了，在老年人社区买了一栋房子。这里太美了。你们有一个后院。你们搬进去没多久，就听说你们家旁边要建一个越野摩托车赛道。你觉得你会有什么感觉？对此有何感想？因此，律师请我作为专家证人出庭。你可以问，越野摩托车赛道建成了吗？答案是没有。虽然可以说我的证词有所帮助，但给我留下深刻印象的是法官的裁决，他指出噪音侵犯了人们的福祉。这给我留下了深刻的印象。我在怀俄明州也有过类似的案子。我也
testified on sound in Canada. I've been invited to speak in Australia. And some of the towns are small. But I tell people, noise can follow you. And I'll give you a perfect example of a man who's now page one of the New York Times, Donald Trump. Marla Lago has planes flying over his home. And you know what he did? He initiated a lawsuit to try to stop the planes. And he had that lawsuit for many years. And I facetiously say, so he ran for president and the planes would stop flying over his home, which followed. They would stop flying once he was president and they dropped the lawsuit. Noise doesn't discriminate. It can go everywhere. You never know in your quiet community, that a facility may be built next to you that will impose noise. And you could be as well
在加拿大就声音问题作证。我应邀在澳大利亚演讲。有些城镇很小。但我告诉人们，噪音会一直跟着你。我给你举一个完美的例子，现在他是《纽约时报》头版的常客，唐纳德·特朗普。海湖庄园有飞机从他家上空飞过。你知道他做了什么吗？他发起了一场诉讼，试图阻止飞机飞行。他打这场官司很多年了。我半开玩笑地说，所以他竞选总统，飞机就会停止在他家上空飞行，事情也确实如此。一旦他当选总统，飞机就会停止飞行，他们也撤回了诉讼。噪音是不分青红皂白的。它无处不在。在你安静的社区里，你永远不知道旁边可能会建起一个设施，带来噪音。你可以像
to do as Donald Trump and you couldn't stop the planes from flying over your home. Now, we all know that New York is a noisy place. Even people who've never been there have seen it in the movies, and they'll know that there's a lot of noise in New York. Is New York the noisiest city in the world? I think it's been rated that, but let me tell you something else about New York. New York passed noise ordinances in the 1930s. We're sort of number one in that also.
唐纳德·特朗普一样富有，但你也无法阻止飞机从你家上空飞过。现在，我们都知道纽约是个嘈杂的地方。甚至那些从未去过那里的人也在电影里看过，他们知道纽约有很多噪音。纽约是世界上最吵闹的城市吗？我想它被评为过，但关于纽约，我还要告诉你另一件事。纽约在20世纪30年代就通过了噪音条例。在这方面我们也算得上是第一名。
New York has me on a site that says if you have a noise. problem, contact Dr. Bronsaf. But remember, I'm writing a letter as a member of a board that's been appointed by the mayor. That carries more clout. I don't think Dr. Bronsaf, professor emeritus city university, would carry that kind of clout. So I think I could say that, yes, being a city. But look, you're thinking of Times Square. And when the ball falls on New Year's Eve, Yes, it's loud. But you know what? That's a pleasurable sound. You might think of our ballparks, of shouts and screams. But you know what? When I go to the Yankee Stadium, that's what I do. You will find that we have areas in New York that are noisy. But you know what? We also have a lot of parks. I live on the Upper East Side. I can walk along the river. During COVID, that was wonderful. I walk along the river back and forth. It's over a mile.
纽约在一个网站上列出了我的名字，上面写着如果你有噪音问题，请联系布朗萨夫博士。但请记住，我是以市长任命的委员会成员身份写信的。这更有分量。我认为城市大学荣誉退休教授布朗萨夫博士不会有那种分量。所以我认为我可以这么说，是的，作为一个城市。但是听着，你想到了时代广场。当新年夜的水晶球落下时，是的，声音很大。但你知道吗？那是一种令人愉快的声音。你可能会想到我们的棒球场，那里有呐喊和尖叫。但你知道吗？当我去洋基体育场时，我就是这么做的。你会发现纽约有些地区很吵闹。但你知道吗？我们也有很多公园。我住在上东区。我可以沿着河边走。在疫情期间，那真是太棒了。我沿着河边来回走。足足有一英里多。
I'm a little further away from Central Park, but I can go to Central Park. You'll see New York has parks. We have green areas. And we have now activists that are saying we have to protect the quiet spaces. We have to enrich our city with these places. and we have to combat helicopter noise. We have that. But we have legislation in the city council saying that we should not permit non-emergency helicopters.
我离中央公园稍远一点，但我也能去中央公园。你会发现纽约有公园。我们有绿地。现在我们有积极分子在说，我们必须保护安静的空间。我们必须用这些地方来丰富我们的城市，我们必须打击直升机噪音。我们有这些。但我们在市议会有立法规定，不应允许非紧急直升机起降。
We have legislation in the state. Now you should ask me, what about the federal government? What have they done about noise? Zero in my estimation. However, if we go back and you're going to have to come up with the president, there was a president that set up the Environmental Protection Agency that gave us the Noise Control Act, that gave us the Clean Air Act, which president? Richard Nixon. Not only did he set up EPA, he put an excellent person in charge of EPA. EPA was coming out with literature. on how harmful noise is to health. In fact, their literature in late 70s said noise
我们在州里有立法。现在你该问我了，联邦政府呢？他们在噪音问题上做了什么？依我之见，是零。然而，如果我们回顾过去，你必须要提到某位总统，曾有一位总统建立了环境保护局，给我们带来了《噪音控制法》，给我们带来了《清洁空气法》，那是哪位总统？理查德·尼克松。他不仅建立了环保局，还任命了一位非常优秀的环保局负责人。环保局当时正在发布有关噪音对健康危害有多大的文献。事实上，他们在70年代末的文献中说，噪音
a health problem. Look how advanced we were in the late 70s. And they were handing out brochures, and they came to cities and talked to people. And then Ronald Reagan was elected president. He essentially shut down the noise on the VPA. But there were a number of presidents after Ronald Reagan. They could have refunded it.
是一个健康问题。看看我们在70年代末是多么先进。他们分发小册子，来到城市与人们交谈。然后罗纳德·里根当选总统。他基本上关闭了环保局的噪音办公室。但在罗纳德·里根之后还有许多总统。他们本可以重新为其提供资金。
The Bushes could have refunded it, right? We could have Clinton could, Obama could, and Biden could certainly refund the noise office. There's legislation introduced in Congress, but they've been doing this for years to try to get funding. But we haven't had an executive order that says, hey, this is a serious problem. Let's get back to what we were doing in the 1970s. And if you come to my home, I can show you their brochures, their pamphlets, and you'd see how active the U.S. was,
老布什和小布什本可以重新资助它，对吧？克林顿可以，奥巴马可以，拜登也完全可以重新资助噪音办公室。国会提出过立法，但多年来他们一直这样做只是为了获得资金。但我们没有发出过行政命令，说，嘿，这是一个严重的问题。让我们回到20世纪70年代我们在做的事情上来。如果你来我家，我可以给你看他们的小册子、印刷品，你就会看到美国曾经多么积极，
no longer. So what are the prospects of that being reinvigorated? Are you doing any work in that area? Yes. I've been working with groups across the country. They are putting pressure. A bill has been introduced by a congressperson, and she has a number of people sign on to the bill. But there's no comparable bill in the Senate. There was one sign. And so what I'm saying is that you have to join a group. You have to talk to people in your community. Numbers count. And And the thing that comforts me, I should be disillusioned after five decades, right? I should say, hey, it hasn't happened. Or I should quote one of my daughters, Mom, you're still talking about noise in the same way.
但现在不再是这样了。那么，这种情况复苏的前景如何？你在那个领域做过什么工作吗？是的。我一直在与全国各地的团体合作。他们正在施加压力。一位国会议员提出了一项法案，她有很多支持该法案的签名。但在参议院没有类似的法案。只有一个签名。所以我想说的是，你必须加入一个团体。你必须与你社区里的人交谈。人数很重要。让我感到安慰的是，经历了五个十年后，我本该幻灭了，对吧？我应该说，嘿，事情并没有发生。或者我应该引用我女儿的话：“妈妈，你还是在用同样的方式谈论噪音。”
Have you accomplished anything, Mom? I don't think you've made much of an impact. My daughters say that with a smile. But what I'm saying, I can tell people that. that when the Senate introduced a bill by a New Jersey senator, he was the key person, to refund a noise abatement back in the 90s, Joe Biden actually signed in to support that legislation. He was definitely supporting it, but nothing happened. So, yes, am I unhappy about it?
妈妈，你有什么成就吗？我觉得你并没有产生多大的影响。我的女儿们笑着说这话。但我想说的是，我可以告诉人们，当参议院由一位新泽西州参议员（他是关键人物）在90年代提出一项为减少噪音提供资金的法案时，乔·拜登实际上签署支持了该立法。他绝对是支持的，但什么也没有发生。所以，是的，我对这感到不高兴吗？
Yes. But what makes me happy is more part. like this one, more press coverage. It isn't either that's getting covered by the press. It's the noise issue that's being covered. And it's getting more attention, and that does give me hope. And I'm going to wait and see because I think we will recognize this dangerous pollut. Let me say something else.
是的。但让我高兴的是更多的节目像这个一样，有更多的媒体报道。受到媒体报道的不仅是这些，还有噪音问题。它正在受到更多的关注，这确实给了我希望。我要拭目以待，因为我认为我们会认识到这种危险的污染物。让我再说点别的。
If studies show that exposure to aircraft noise increases, or risk of going to a hospital for a cardiovascular disorder, that's going to cost money. When you allow noise to prevail, it's costly. So even though the airlines say, oh, if we make changes and they are exploring changes, let me tell you that they are, that could be costly. What's more costly than medical health in this country? think the military they beat it. But when you do not take care of a noise problem, like the children who were a year behind a reading, how much would it have cost to try to improve their reading
如果研究表明接触飞机噪音会增加，或者增加因心血管疾病去医院就诊的风险，那将花费金钱。当你任由噪音蔓延时，代价是高昂的。因此，尽管航空公司说，哦，如果我们做出改变，而且他们正在探索改变，让我告诉你，他们确实在探索，但这可能会付出高昂的代价。在这个国家，还有什么比医疗健康代价更高呢？我想军队的开支可能超过了它。但是，当你不管不顾噪音问题时，就像那些落后阅读进度一年的儿童一样，试图提高他们的阅读成绩要花多少钱？
scores? They were nearly a year behind. If you don't lessen noise pollution, it will cost this country in terms of dollars. And I want that factored in when the FAA's approach. to provide quieter aircraft and quieter routes. One of the things that I ran into when I was prepping for this interview was the fact that there's something now called a noise camera. What are these instruments and where are they being used? What are they supposed to do? They're in the pilot study stage. New York has the pilot study. And they've done it in several cities in the U.S. and in Europe. Europe's a little bit ahead of us.
他们落后了将近一年。如果你不减少噪音污染，这个国家将付出了金钱方面的代价。我希望在联邦航空局采取方法提供更安静的飞机和更安静的航线时，将这一点考虑在内。我在为这次采访做准备时遇到的事情之一是，现在有一种叫做噪音相机的仪器。这些仪器是什么，它们在哪里使用？它们的目的是什么？它们正处于试点研究阶段。纽约有这个试点研究。他们在美国的几个城市和欧洲都做过。欧洲比我们稍微领先一点。
Actually, when it comes to funding research and noise, Europe is definitely ahead of us. The camera works, the way a speed camera works. When a car with modified mufflets that come to the corner blasting through, a picture is taken of license and the sound level is registered. one of the problems early on was that if there was a car next to you, that could be added to the sound level so that it's not your car that made loud sound. It was a contribution by the car next to you. So they had to work that out.
事实上，在资助噪音研究方面，欧洲绝对领先于我们。相机的工作原理就像测速相机一样。当一辆改装了消音器的汽车呼啸着开过街角时，就会拍下一张车牌的照片，并记录下声级。早期的问题之一是，如果你旁边有一辆车，那可能会增加到声级中，所以发出巨响的不是你的车。而是你旁边那辆车的贡献。所以他们必须解决这个问题。
And so New York City now is a pilot study, and they have found that when people are penalized, that there's less noise in the area, but they only have a few cameras. They haven't yet issued a full report on it, but it's a way of trying to get people to recognize that they cannot make noise on the road, just as there are rules by which your cars are guided with respect to speed. There are rules with respect to noise. So this is being explored and people are interested in it. One last question.
因此，纽约市现在正在进行试点研究，他们发现当人们受到惩罚时，该地区的噪音就会减少，但他们只有几台相机。他们还没有发布关于它的完整报告，但这是一种试图让人们认识到他们不能在路上制造噪音的方法，就像有关于你的汽车行驶速度的规则一样。有关于噪音的规则。所以这正在被探索，人们对此很感兴趣。最后一个问题。
I want to ask you, what are the strangest noise complaints that you've gotten? Can you just hit me with one or two of those? Okay. A woman called me, an older woman, and said a car was parked in front of her apart in building, small building, blasting music late at night. and then she would hear footsteps going upstairs and downstairs, and she couldn't sleep. I said, what's going on? So her aide got on the phone, said Dr. Bronset, they're dealing drugs above.
我想问你，你接到的最奇怪的噪音投诉是什么？你能给我说一两个那样的例子吗？好的。一个女人打电话给我，一个老妇人，说一辆车停在她公寓大楼前，一个小建筑，深夜放着震耳欲聋的音乐，然后她会听到楼上楼下的脚步声，她睡不着觉。我说，怎么回事？于是她的助手接起电话说，布朗萨夫博士，他们在楼上毒品交易。
And I must say, I went to the precinct of that Brooklyn community, spoke to them, and they said, we'll look into it. They did. The drug dealing was shut down. down. The next call I got was from the landlord who had been so frightened he couldn't do anything about it, thanking me profusely and said I will do everything for that person. Now I'm going to give you another one. I get a complaint that the person next door to this other couple are hearing the bed banging against the wall at night when the couple has sex.
我必须说，我去了那个布鲁克林社区的警察局，跟他们谈了谈，他们说，我们会调查的。他们照做了。毒品交易被查封了。我接到的下一个电话是房东打来的，他吓坏了，对此束手无策，他对我千恩万谢，并说我将为那个人做一切事情。现在我再给你讲一个。我接到一个投诉，说这另一对夫妇隔壁的人晚上听到床撞击墙壁的声音，当这对夫妇做爱时。
that's a touchy one. Fortunately, it was in my building, and I knew the housekeeper of that apartment. And I approached, I said, you know, the people next door are saying the bed bangs against the wall. So I would suggest you move the bed a few inches away from the wall, and that's how that problem was solved. And then I'll give you my one early case. A man decided to build a windmill in his back. I actually went out to New Jersey and listened to that windmill. And I can tell you, even when I walked into her home, it was still in my head. The good news, the windmill was taken down. And from what I hear, that case is discussed in law classes. So sex, drug dealing, windmills, I don't think you can come up with something that I haven't yet. Well, I want to thank you for joining me today and thank you for making the world a little bit less noisy.
这是一个敏感的话题。幸好它就在我的大楼里，我认识那个公寓的管家。我走过去说，你知道，隔壁的人说床撞击了墙壁。所以我建议你把床往外挪几英寸，问题就是这样解决的。然后我给你讲我早期的一个案子。一个男人决定在后院建一个风车。我实际上去了新泽西州听了那个风车。我可以告诉你，即使我走进她的家，它依然在我的脑海里回响。好消息是，风车被拆除了。据我所听到的，这个案子在法学课上被讨论过。所以性、毒品交易、风车，我想你不可能想出什么我还不知道的东西。好吧，我想感谢你今天加入我，也感谢你让世界变得不那么嘈杂一点。
Well, let me just say, quiet enhances health. I didn't say silence because I still want to hear birds. I still want to hear the air blowing and I still want to hear the babbling of young children. Thank you. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website. at www. www. speakingof psychology.org or on Apple, Spotify, YouTube, or wherever you get your podcasts. And if you like what you've heard, please subscribe and give us a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org.
好吧，我只想说，安静能促进健康。我没有说死寂，因为我仍然想听到鸟儿的叫声。我仍然想听到微风吹拂的声音，我仍然想听到幼儿的牙牙学语声。谢谢。您可以在我们的网站上找到《心理学对话》之前的节目，网址是 www.speakingofpsychology.org，或者在 Apple、Spotify、YouTube 或您获取播客的任何地方收听。如果您喜欢我们的节目，请订阅并给我们留下评价。如果您对未来的播客有任何意见或想法，可以发电子邮件至 speakingofpsychology@apa.org。
Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Weinerman. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. Enjoy more ways to save at Ralph's, like low prices in every aisle. And when you download the Ralph's app, you can clip and save more with digital coupons every week. Plus, you can earn fuel points to save up to $1 per gallon at the pump. At Ralph's, you can enjoy more ways to save and more rewards every time you shop. So it's always easy to save big every day with savings and rewards.
《心理学对话》由李·韦纳曼制作。感谢您的收听。我是金·米尔斯，代表美国心理学协会。在罗尔斯超市享受更多省钱方式，例如每个过道都有的低价。当你下载罗尔斯超市应用程序时，你每周都可以通过数字优惠券剪裁并节省更多。此外，你还可以赚取积分，在加油站每加仑节省高达1美元。在罗尔斯超市，每次购物都可以享受更多省钱方式和更多奖励。因此，通过节省和奖励，每天都可以轻松省大钱。
Ralph's SoCal for over 150 years. Savings may vary by state. Fuel restrictions apply. by C-Site for details. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
罗尔斯南加州分店已超过150年。各州的节省金额可能会有所不同。燃油限制适用。请查看网站了解详情。本期节目尚无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。